are you out of your mind here's the
debate
[Music]
gentlemen we're live fantastic folks
today we have a special guest for you
it's diamond dallas paige the one and
only diamond dallas page i don't know
how many championships you've got how
many times
let me just read off of read off a few
of them so folks know
uh what you did over a decade in wcw
three-time wcw world heavyweight
champion two-time wcw united states
heavyweight champion four-time wcw world
tag team champion one time wcw world
television champion
fort wcw triple crown champion this list
goes on you
uh uh and the only us heavyweight
champion to defend the title on a
pay-per-view main event defeating bret
hart at uh the 1998 world war three you
have a new
program called the ddpy which some would
call yoga but you created it yourself
and you said something very interesting
when we just got started you said when
you guys started wrestling you know the
hulk was six seven and you were six four
and you're still six four and he's now
six three so nine six four probably
about the same height yeah right about
the same yeah
eye-to-eye we'll talk about we'll talk
about how you did that how you recreated
the solo identity but pretty excited
about this interview man great to have
you on oh bob pleasure to be here bro
pleasure to be here we've had some
certified badasses on the show we had
francis pagano the ufc heavyweight
champion the world but i mean ddp
certified badass in the house
and you know what but i'm also an actor
you know he's he's a real badass
and you know i do it i can hang my own
but at 66 i'm all about peace and love
baby
it's like the old bobby bear song you're
the winner as far as i'm concerned you
win you know
i'm not trying to fight it by the way by
the way
for the folks who are still in their 40s
or 50s and they were convinced wrestling
was real he just ruined it for you
i always tell people it's not fake it's
pre-determined yeah
it's going on it's a show it's a show
yeah i gotta tell you it's a great story
i was i was uh
being interviewed because we did one of
the favorite wrestling movies out there
is ready to rumble and you know we're
doing the whole big you know gambit the
promoting and everything and everybody's
being so nice because wrestling's just
white hot you know in the 90s and that's
when it came out and there's this one
guy who's interviewing me and i can tell
he just doesn't want to be there and so
as we get to the end of the interview i
said you know can i ask you a question
man you go sure i said you don't
appreciate what we do do you
he said honestly i said i asked you a
question yeah honestly because not
really
i said
okay so you don't like the whole
showmanship of it or whatever
let me ask you a question
i said
uh are you like you guys you're from new
york city yo you a guy who likes to go
to place oh absolutely i love i love
broadway i said what's your favorite uh
broadway play and he said hands down
phantom of the opera
and i looked around
and i said bro
i don't want to spoil this for you
but he doesn't really get burnt with
the crew just burst out laughing right
and
uh yeah i decided i said you know every
night i'm going out there with a
different opponent because it's a dance
it's a very
physical brutal dance and people think
it only happens on monday and friday in
a pay-per-view no it happens 24
to 27
nights a month
you get in a car you drive 100 200 300
miles to the next town or fly from l.a
to kansas city and drive 100 200 300
miles the wear and tear on your body
is off the chain and people can say
whatever they want about professional
wrestling
one thing remains that everyone
understands
you can't fake gravity
you know gravity wolf
it'll lift you up i mean you said you
your surgery what would you on your back
what did you talk about you had
something going with your back i i knew
this is a thing now we talked about hulk
a second you know from what i understand
hulk said eight
back surgeries because once you start
one
they're coming
i ruptured my elf i didn't start
wrestling until i was 35 my career took
off when i was 40. that was in
most professional careers are ending at
that point you're just getting this
thing started baby and it it was really
hard because i came from a manager in a
color color come a color commentator
spot and i was running nightclubs so
for me to make that yo break because
one day they came up to me on the wcw at
the time i'm managing scott hall who i
called the diamond stud at the time and
i'm managing to free birds and magnum ta
who is dusty rhodes's right hand walks
up to me and he says listen deep
we're still going to let you do the
color commentating but we can't let you
do the you know the managing anymore i
go why i mean dude what did i do wrong i
go i'll fix it he goes
honestly
you can't i go what do you mean i can't
he goes because
look at you
the hair had long unbelievable gorgeous
hair yeah yeah i'm drinking lots of gold
rocks golden air but you know the
clothes the bling the wraps i had these
girls called the diamond dolls yeah and
they were stripper hot it was like
smoking i know the type d yeah you know
what i'm talking about
and the bottom line is
he's like the bling the rap the girls
nobody
everybody wants to be you you're taking
two we need you in the ring bro do you
know what he was getting at no he was
saying you basically i'm too over the
top for professional wrestling how is
that possible as a manager
but what he said when he walked away he
said what we should have tried to do is
put you in a pair of tights and boots
and see if you can do this now i had
seven months left of my contract
at that point i was like you know i
never got in this business because i
tried it when i was 23. and three
matches hurt my knees it didn't work out
for me i wasn't ready for it then anyway
starting at 35
was really hard because when i can't
tell you how many times my body hit that
mat when i first got down that cold
gym that tree and seven different rings
in it and it's freezing in there i can't
tell you how many times my body hit that
mat and i thought man this fake [ __ ]
hurts like hell
yeah you know
so you know it's just
the when i finally got to
you know actually get there and then
find out okay now you can't do it why
seven months left to my contract so i
said to help i'm going down to power
plant
i'm gonna learn how to wrestle now the
guys i was managing the free birds the
two of the greatest ever hall of famers
jimmy jam garvin michael psas
they looked at each other
and literally fell down laughing at me
because by the time you try to figure it
out because it's not like anything
you've ever done
if you're in a fight you're in a fight
you're in a fight fight with a mixed
martial artist you're in trouble because
those cats know all different types from
jiu jitsu to wrestling and boxing
striking everything like they're going
to get you in every different angle but
at least you got your own you got two
fish you got something to go with in
professional wrestling it's a dance
and just falling flat on your back
there's nothing
normal about that so you got to
reprogram your mind to understand how to
focus if you don't take as much of it to
fall from your shoulders to your hips
you know you can really hurt yourself so
the bottom line is you think that
learning those moves in the beginning
it's going to be the hardest thing
you've ever done
and now you're from out there in front
of 500 5 000
i've been in front of 101 000 people
[Music]
and
once you realize now you're on from
those people
now how do you make them care and think
about this
when they know
that you know
and you know that they know that you and
your partner both know who's gonna win
before you walk out there how do you
make them care
you build real life characters
and and i i've often said this in my
speaking
and
when paige joseph faulkenberg because
that was my real name before i change it
and i knew that name was never going to
draw any money in the world of
professional wrestling when paige joseph
fuckerberg stopped trying to be this
over-the-top
wrestling persona diamond dallas page
and diamond dallas page started thinking
on the characteristics of paige joseph
falkenberg work ethic belief in oneself
discipline
man my career took off like a rocket
because i was bringing my own self to
the character and that's what every
single actor does
you know and
creates backstory so now though became
all mine i am the oldest rookie ever
inside my hall of fame ring it says work
ethic equals dreams explanation
i love that i love that what a freaking
story you just told by the way uh in in
in a match you're saying all of it is
you know you kind of know who's gonna
win before has there ever been a time
where in the middle of it it changed
where you guys as the wrestlers made a
decision now you know what you're going
to win this one but not like that though
eddie guerrero was one of the greatest
wrestlers ever he could do
anything and
we were having a match at halloween
havoc and this was really got me to a
place where eddie was
the good guy when we started i was the
bad guy but my diamond cutter finishing
maneuver because it came out of nowhere
people want to be surprised they want to
think they know no no no oh
they want to be surprised and again ours
is like ballet
meets broadway meets live acting
and eddie
he would come off that top rope to you
on the floor when nobody did that now a
lot of guys do it i did it you know but
at that time he was one of the only guys
who was doing it and he would be
to jump off that top deal which was
probably about 12 feet so he's another
20 feet in the air and he came down and
how he landed and this happened to me
too at times when you tear like a in
between your ribs white muscle
it's you can't breathe it hurts to
breathe and eddie never sold it in other
words he never told me he hurt himself
he kept going he kept going and we're
getting near the end of the match and i
go to pick him up he goes diamond cutter
i go no eddie go diamond cutter done he
was
okay
it was diamond cutter opinion it was a
huge win for me
october of 1996 uh 1996.
1997 i'd be the wrestler of the year
well you were supposed to lose that
match and he was that injured he's like
ddp me now yes just just hit me hit me
with the freaking how quickly did it
register oh [ __ ] i'm about to win this
match uh i was like you know i hope i
don't get in trouble
and did you what happened
because eddie was like he came out like
he was really he would jump off the top
rope and he would take his arm his leg
as far out and then he'd bring his knees
into his chest and he'd spring out he
goes to call it a frog splash he wasn't
doing that and i thought he just should
have rolled me up and just like you know
made something's really simple to get
the win but he didn't do it he went
diamond cutter went okay
it was a huge win
for me
wow so so 96 96 so let me ask you so you
know how
uh uh the game of football right okay
the quarterback's up there coach is
calling to play sometimes the players
like now i'm going to do what i'm going
to do and the coach loses their mind
they're going to be doing that what are
you doing this is not going to throw
this over here can't say nothing about
and then there's that beef between the
player
when that happens there who's calling
who is vince calling saying what was
that all about how does that process go
that was actually eric bischoff who was
in charge at that point because we were
kicking their ass well we were going
back and forth in 96 97 98 we kicked
wwe's ass they almost went out of
business
nwo was the hottest thing it was
must-see tv this is how crazy it was
the top you know back then it was as
many channels as that but it was a lot
of them so on cable television
we would be
or wwf would be number one in all of
cable and then we would be our wwf would
be
number two
number three and sometimes number four
we had the top
four shows on all of cable and it was
two different shows we did nitro and uh
thunder they did raw and smackdown
it was crazy in the ratings originally
vince was doing like a 2.9 to a 3.2 that
would be unbelievable today but the
universe has changed
we got those numbers up i thought
they're going to split one way to get
one five and you know you know one eight
or whatever
no no
more people watched
more people watched and it's kind of
like the boston red sox and the yankees
those two teams hate each other and not
not so much the teams but the but the
fans
and if the if all of a sudden there was
no more red sox all those baseball fans
who watching red sox would start
watching soccer or something they
wouldn't watch the yankees you know
because they hate them so i don't
understand that but i my buddies i grew
up in jersey
they you know like made a plane crash
why would you say that like they're that
fanatical about it so that's what it was
in wcw so by the way were you going to
be i were you at that time like but but
was it did the world also say that
you're ahead of them like that the world
because i know you guys had hulk hogan
you had you know eric bischoff you had
kevin nash you had scott hall you had
randy savage you had sting you had you
had so many guys scott steiner i mean
[ __ ] some of these names bagwell norton
there was some legit lineup of what you
guys had yeah what were you ahead were
you like the yankees at the time or were
you the red sox underdog we were we were
the redheaded stepchild for the longest
time and then kevin nash and scott hall
one day they were on their tv
and the next day scott hall just showed
up on ours there was only five people
who knew he's gonna walk through the
crowd
walk through the grab a microphone in
the middle of a match people like what
the hell is happening
and then he said he's uh we're gonna we
want you we're gonna bring our best
three you bring your best friend he puts
out this challenge
it we call it a shoot you know like this
is this is not a work or it's not not
storyline it was but nobody knew but the
smallest handful you know really tough
to do during the internet but you can
still do it but you don't know if it's
real or not no kevin nash showed up he
grabbed eric bischoff and this had never
been done vince mcmahon would go on to
have matches and get thrown through
stuff and slam through stuff but it
never happened before eric bischoff
kevin nash grabbed them at six foot ten
picked him up over his head and
threw him
through the stage now it's set up to
break but he drops like 10 feet
through a broken stage down to the
ground and that's how they go off the
show so now people are they they bought
it
is vince because these guys were just on
tv and they were razor ramon and diesel
when those guys came on
they never said their names it was you
know who we are
so now it didn't they didn't have to
call them something else and their names
were cool scott hall kevin nash hall and
nash they became the outsiders it
changed the business
it made it what thursdays used to be
when seinfeld was on and stuff must see
tv and guys would be picking up the
phone oh my god no switch over switch
over to wwf i'll switch over to wcw
and
through this
because it was so hot both of those guys
were best friends of mine we started
together i created scott hall's look
when he came in as a diamond stud
and he didn't he had the blonde hair and
a big walrus mustache and he completely
changed his look
and
he wanted to help me
back
you know and kevin nash we were tag team
partners and
he wanted to quit a bunch of times
because they were screwing them around
so bad that i would be like don't let
them beat you big man you're gonna be
one of the biggest names of all time and
he is but even even his hall of fame
speech he thanked me because i got my my
home on the beach you know because a
dolly kept me in this
you know keeping that positive don't you
know this you know this you don't quit
you keep if you believe in it if you're
passionate about it you keep moving
towards it and it will happen and it may
not happen exactly when you want it to
happen but it'll happen you know it's
crazy i i uh one of our guys that i was
reading the text you earlier he texts me
from brazil aaron and he says he knows
obviously you're going to be on the show
today says have an awesome show today
patrick what www what ddp did for jake
uh uh the snake was nothing short of
amazing i said which part he says he
brought jake the snake back from a
massive alcoholic alcohol addiction
rehabbed his body and helped him be able
to be inducted into wwe hall of fame he
has done that for many athletes this is
a very common thread with the story of
what you've done for these guys
what what what have what has been your
approach and you know maybe the better
question would be in every sport there
is a guy that plays that role older
brother like somebody that's going to
give the call and say you you know let
me talk to you let's kind of help you
get through this challenge in time
what is the what is the optics of what
this looks like meaning party and
temptation what's around me what's the
life look like i remember i went to ric
flair's place in atlanta
he was in atlanta i interviewed rick
flair
and he told me the stories
in there with rick and this girl is
sitting over there you know
and we're going back and forth i'm like
oh half the stories he's telling me it
doesn't make any sense that's when the
documentary had come out and the whole
story with his son 24 years old
emotional all of this stuff but tell me
what the world looks like that we don't
see we see this but we don't see behind
the scenes the party what does that life
look like well but first let me tell you
ric flair
like
there was nobody like him there's nobody
to me he's one of he's the greatest of
all time because he had the 30-year run
of being on top he's still on top at 73.
you know everybody loves him uh but his
stories when he's telling you how wild
and crazy they are they're watered down
because you know
you can take those strategies
yeah his is like the quadruple x uh yo
the nate
is his own animal i love him to death uh
we didn't we in early in my career
because i'm coming up at the 35 37 he
doesn't believe in me likes me he
doesn't believe me so he's not gonna we
end up have a little bit of conflict and
then later
after you know it's all gone because
we're all family we all love each other
when it's all said and done
very few guys have the heat that lasts
forever really yeah so there's a
brotherly love throughout all of
wrestling
we're a total dysfunctional family
like we can do [ __ ] back and forth with
each other but you don't get to do it
you know i love it
and me and nate i saw him
uh they dropped all the balloons for wwf
who was a big thing wwe you know for
he's retiring and i thought man i've
always loved this guy as ric flair
i you know i wanted to have be tight
with rick but it just didn't happen
so i said i'm gonna i'm gonna try and
fix this so we were both at a signing in
new york
and everybody is
he's rick flair so you know he just got
retired for so everybody swarms him and
i wait till everybody was done he's like
hey diamond how you doing i go good rick
i go can i talk to you for a sec he goes
absolutely i said you know rick i go
i know me and you have had heat you know
over the years and he's like oh come on
dee don't don't worry about that i go
rick i'm not worried about it
i want to fix it
i know i've said some [ __ ] i know you
said some [ __ ]
i said dude i go i don't want ric flair
to not
be one of my boys i don't want me
to feel that way i said i would love
to start all over again
i'm going to put up my hands
i'm diamond dallas page
and he popped and he hugged me he kissed
me on the board god bless your brother
and since then
i've had such an unbelievable
relationship i love ric flair
uh when i went in the hall of fame uh
that night before i was leaving he
yelled to me he was at the bar i come
over he goes dee come on sit down have a
drink have a drink so have a drink with
him and he says what time's your flight
tomorrow i said 7 30. he's like jesus
who booked that i go not me and i can't
change the fight he goes you're still in
atlanta i said yeah i'm still in atlanta
he goes he goes all right he goes
tomorrow you and your old lady man
go
i got the limousine i got the lyric out
i got my whole deal yo you're coming
back to atlanta with me i go rick that
is so cool but bro i don't i've got so
many bags i'm like the gris walls you
and he's like i don't want to hear that
[ __ ] get down there's a fedex right over
there he goes send your bags home i'll
meet you down here don't call me before
12. we're leaving it too and
we went we
flew us back in the lear jet he found
out was my birthday took us out to
dinner said i mean mcfly i mean i love
him to death but i'm telling you his
stories
they're watered down you know because
he's he is just pure energy and he's the
nature boy
who are your best friends in the
business it sounds like there's a
brotherhood even if there's beef
you're the type of person i'm just
you're infectious as hell bro
i feel like if you're in a room you're
gonna be the first guy to be like man
just put it here bro like i feel like
that's that's that's huge that's huge to
do especially in a competitive
environment but at the end of the day
who are like your tightest guys that
you're tight with the tightest guys i'm
you know kevin nash you know scott hall
jake roberts uh dusty rhodes before he
left uh stone cold steve austin
eric bischoff you know it's funny
because when scott passed boy
whoo it really hit because you know you
we just talked about james a month ago
right now a month ago
um jacob um
what happened let's go back to the
resurrection because you got to really
see how that happened without jake
without dusty rose there is no diamond
dallas page he gave me all the breaks
and the mentoring that because he loved
me and he pulled me under his wing and
he saw me more as a producer you know
and and a talent like you know on airtel
not a wrestler i would do that later
and um
jake snake roberts pulled me under his
wing i i this is how i meet jake snake
roberts i've got this big ass club in
fort myers florida
and
right now we're writing a show about
this and this is how it starts
club you have to go this is the 80s so
think of it as like welcome to the
jungle the music's playing you see the
62 pink cadillac pull into the club the
place is packed hair band is just like
all-time high at that point no crazy
right the energy's insane everybody's
partying it's pre-aids it's you know
it's it's a bunch of wild people having
a good time and and
the character who plays me gets out of
the car just what really happens i get
out of the car i go to the club you're
the mayor there's a thousand plus people
in there buying drinks blah blah blah
working your way through the crowd i get
to the back i reach over i go to grab my
keys
that are you know with right where the
monitors are front door back door and i
see
the sky fill up the screen on the
monitor and i'm like
no way
and i run not through the build not
through the building around the outside
of the building because i won't be able
to find him in there
and i walked in the front door i go judy
did a guy walk in here look like jake to
snake roberts she's like yeah everybody
thinks it's him so like the biggest mark
ever i go running in there
i see him and i slow down because i
don't want to be all fanboyed up on jake
roberts
and i finally worked my way over to him
and like hey man
you jake to snake roberts
who wants to know
i said the guy runs this place yes
what can i do for you
what are we drinking and we am getting
so shit-faced that night and it was the
beginning of being bar buddies and
come he would come in the club and other
boys would because i didn't charge
anybody i took care of them all gave
them a safe place to be this is before
i'm involved in this [ __ ] but i tried it
when i was 23. so i had this thing
connection connection to it and then
later on
jake when i when i would be in wcw
and i started wrestling jake came in for
like three months got this huge contract
and then before he signed it
another guy came in bill watts and said
pulled the contract off the table
and then jake was out of there because
they had a lot of conflict between the
two of them
and what ended up happening is i tore my
rotator cuff
and jake had called me because now
i'm wrestling nine months
actually seven months because my
contract's up they're not going to renew
it i'm 36 years old my cut my rotator
cuff's gone yeah i got to get surgery on
it jake calls me up and just you know
sees how i'm doing him and his old lady
had split up before you know it he's
living with me and my wife my first wife
at the time
and so
he takes me under his wing and you know
i'm like man i can't wait wow we're
gonna do independent
you work independently there's
independent wrestling all over the world
and you can make decent money i was at
the bottom of the card but jake could
get me in
and one of the things he said to me
which was really really like it changed
my whole life but it came
to this world and how fast i learned
i filmed every match i ever had
and jake had sold me i said to him man i
can't wait when's my shoulders better i
can't wait to get in the ring and work
with you he goes yeah yeah he goes but
you've already got all the moves down
you already know what to do in the ring
you just don't know why
you don't know how to tell a story yet
he goes we're going to learn more
watching your matches
and me critiquing them than you will
ever learn from me in the ring think of
game films
right i mean every single person from
every world
has game films
except for wrestling
and i started filming myself the guys
would bust my chops so bad i'm the first
guy to ice his body
knees and back later and shoulders later
just to getting out of the ring icing my
body
and then i'm the first guy to film his
matches look on youtube today
there's a billion kids who've got their
match
up on youtube
and if you really watch it with someone
who really understands and whether it
was me and nash or scott hall or or
austin or mcfarly whoever it was
you know we'd sit back and drink beers
and watch the matches that i just filmed
and they would all help me critique me
and jake was the real mind though so let
me ask you this so what matters the most
in your world okay so you got first of
all your voice is ridiculous your voice
again you know what i'm saying like you
can listen to that voice tell stories
all day long
clearly it'll kick your ass so how much
how much of it is phys like physiology
like what you look like how much of it
is your look your face how much of it is
your voice how much of it is
storytelling how much of it is talking
[ __ ] how much of it is just real
flexibility
what would you rank as the most
important to being a great wrestler
you're really insightful bro because
it's all of that
when you've got the look
and the size
and the rap
and the athleticism
when you put that all together
you've got like stone cold steve austin
you've got the rock you've got a gum
goldberg
you know you've got kevin nash like
the
guys who
guys who learned to just take themselves
and amp them up
and scott because he was big scott hall
or he was gator scott hall
he didn't really know how to be like
himself and help himself up until i
managed him and we create that look i
told you about the black hair and brush
cut five o'clock shadow which he had
around two you know
uh
have you seen his beard of course can
you pull him up real quick
he's got like a perfect perfect yeah
and he's got
can and try to pull up a picture of him
with a mustache too
like an older picture so you can see it
doesn't look anything like this
type of mustache next to it yeah it's
like a walrus mustache
let's see look at does that look
anything like the other guy
not at all
not at all
that's scott hall right there that's
scott that's big scott and when did he
become razor ramon well what happened
was when i come up with this idea for
the diamond stud he's the one who calls
me and says you know we could do that
diamond stud gimmick you know and i said
well you you know they didn't want to
bring him in because he'd already been
in and once you've had a chance you're
kind of out you know like sometimes it's
too early and it was too early for him
to get the big opportunity
but if you change his luck and that's
what i told magnum ta the guy who told
me i was too over the top professional
wrestling as a manager
he he said uh
you know
they've already seen them and they don't
want to bring them back in i go banks
what if i can completely change his luck
because what do you mean i go what if
you don't recognize him
so he goes just bring him up bring him
up we'll take a look at him so i call
scott and i say dude
i said you gotta you know they don't
want you and it just crushed him you
know it's like he just got back from
germany wrestling there and he can't get
wwf wwe or wcw to call him back
but he's got me here and i'm going
you got what if we change the color of
your hair
i go he goes what do you mean i go like
go from like the blonde or dirty blonde
hair to the blue black like elvis hair
and hockey talk man had black hair like
that the honky tonk man was great yeah
and it's but he was the only one who had
that hair like that it was elvis right
yeah of course and and then you bring on
um
you know the the uh
i saw i saw sean uh i'm not sure michael
i saw uh george michaels on mtv at two
o'clock in the morning because i'm a
club guy still even though i'm staying
with my buddy in atlanta i can't go to
bed that early so i see george michael
on and he had this five o'clock shadow
look i go man that looks amazing so i
pick up the phone and i call him
dally what are you doing bro it's two in
the morning my wife's pregnant you know
i go come here i gotta tell you
something you're coming up tomorrow come
on walk out of the room i go you got to
save shave the mustache
shave the mustache
like dude i've had this since i was 15 i
go just another reason shave them the
tom selleck look is done brother she's
over we gotta put the five o'clock
shadow george michael vibes so the
bottom line is he did it
no one recognized them and they kind of
imagine you you know what you look like
yeah and you saw this guy six months ago
and now dude that's the example right
there look at that exactly
no that's not gonna look like the same
guy
crazy
it's like getting out of the 80's into
the 2000's hey yo he would say hey yo
who would say chico who would say him to
him
you know your stuff right well i mean
listen i mean i'm 43. this is my era
i've watched who was your favorite
wrestler growing up who was your guy
the obvious one is the iron sheik
what you guys say listen i appreciate
that yeah
do you know what a stud iron cheek used
to be yeah that's what i hear he was an
animal bro he was 185 pound olympic
athlete he was no sergeant slaughter
yeah dude
who was your guy another great guy i
would say i mean in my era
uh [ __ ] lex luger was always going to
see him coming out
who was the other guy the
ultimate warrior was was uh
you like the gym guys i like the gym
guys yeah i like the i like to listen
goldberg to me
was that's a little later but goldberg
was insane to watch him nash sting
uh who was the other guy there was one
other guy that was uh
i'll look him up i'll i'll see but
anyways this was an error i was watching
him but you go go back to your story on
what you were talking about with him so
he changed his love so i just look yeah
and now i've got a 62 pink cadillac
convertible that's what i drive at the
time
and aretha franklin box let's see what
it looks like
62 cadillac pink convertible
and we're driving scott didn't even
drink back that he did he smoked pot and
he'd be rolling that's a 59 got to get a
62. that's a 59. tyler it's a 59 [ __ ]
you put in if you put diamond dials page
pink cadillac
it might come up over there
um jacked up right now he loved the
movie scarface
so he would be you know
smoking an herb and just doing wonders
there's a million quotes yeah from
scotland my friend mario does that
nonstop
and and so what happened was when he
went to the wwf i'd heard i can't i
don't know if it was true or not but i'm
pretty sure he told me that vince wanted
to make him like gi bro or would not
yeah bro but
an army guy and he said you know vince
what do you think about this and they
went into the character and then slapped
it and then
one of my very good friends gabriel
glacier the comedian
said yeah fluffy fluffy said he cried
when he realized he wasn't mexican
he still still loves still he's just a
white guy
he's a white guy the right guy
but he played it so well he played
better than mexicans
i want to address one thing we're
talking about this guys i gotta just
hand it head on
my favorite wrestler all time growing up
i'm an 80s kid 90s kid
straight up it wasn't anything close to
hulk hogan i am a real american i mean
are you kidding me when you're a kid
growing up you're just like
hell yeah i mean hulk i mean he's got
his 62 inch ply though whatever no look
there was there was the ultimate warrior
those macho man ready
i mean jake the snake million dollar man
ted dibiase super fried jimmy snuck up
junk like i loved wrestling but nobody
was hulk hogan now he was is he the goat
who's the goat now he said rick flair
he's the first person to say i gotta say
rick when it because you gotta add the
work in there too like rick could do
16-minute broadways meaning he's gonna
wrestle for 60 minutes with no winner at
the end
you know i mean like he's that guy and
but if you take the icon who at the time
was the hottest it's hulkster you know
but you look at a guy like sean michaels
who was
just a younger version who could could
do i mean he did stuff at it's just an
unbelievable different level if stone
cold steve austin has the length of ric
flair when it comes to longevity because
he got trapped on his head and broke his
neck
uh you know maybe he's the guy because
he drew money he drew more money than
hulk drew in a shorter period of time
yeah because remember so he's like
connor he would put money
say again because connor you know
countering ufc
right right right right and that's
austin and austin i mean i know they're
both i'll tell you when you get to that
level the grab how you grab the crowd
like i was so
lucky to live the dream like i did man
1997 was my year 1998 was amazing in 99
and this is all in my 40s
crazy you know all in my 40s and what
ended up happening where ddp yoga thing
comes from
i'm working 270
plus days a year hitting the mat
one match because i'm one main events
through all this so one match could go
15 minutes ago 30.
that's like having five
to eight
car accidents
in one day
and ric flair said something really you
know interesting he said it's amazing
what your body can get used to
so pain tolerance yes
but just your body can you just keep get
used to it
and then when you stop doing it you come
back oh my god it's like starting all
over again
so i was working such a feverish pitch
along with doing you know malone carl
malone
and dennis rodman
king rodman was with hogan and me and
carl malone came in
while they were on the tonight show and
we shot the angle showed malone and ddp
and i have to teach these guys now
how to wrestle
they're not wrestlers so we have to
figure out malone is here there you go
look at that picture right beast
like that is the
i i'll go back and tell you the story so
hulk holds me aside in germany 1994.
i just walked through the curtain
and he pulls me aside he goes how are
you doing it
i go how am i doing what hulk he goes
how are you getting so much better he
goes i don't see you on tv that often
they don't believe in me at the time
they're not using me
so he goes but when i do see you you
come up with some new move i haven't
seen you do and you get the people
involved he goes this is how they're
doing it right he answers his own
question he goes they're putting you on
the road so you can learn your craft
as hell as an oak the only reason i'm on
this tour
is because my real name is faulkenberg
and the krauts love their germans
and i got a smoking hot wife that walks
me to the ring he goes well how the hell
are you doing it then i said i went back
down to power plant where i learned how
to wrestle
and i started teaching those guys and
i'm kind of figuring out the more i
teach them the more i learn this is
about everything you know this of course
if you teach someone and keep teaching
them and keep teaching you're learning
as you're teaching the most the most
important thing so
and obviously
great talk i'm thank you i appreciate
the compliment he goes he goes whatever
you're doing
keep doing it because it's not today
it's not next year the year after he
said but i honest to god believe
that you and i could draw huge money
together well
four years later
that is the big second biggest drawing
pay-per-view in the history of
pay-per-views for wcw
and
i'm the one who put that whole thing
together from carl coming in rodman was
already coming in with hulk but i put
the idea together brought up the bishop
bishop saw malone you know
sweep la that year and he said let's do
it and it happened so
it's you know getting you never know
who's watching
you know that's uh that's one of the
little
things i explain to people you know you
what if you're going to clean out your
bathroom or sweep a floor
like do it the right way
because somebody's watching and it might
just change your life that's so powerful
by the way
you never know who's watching no well
listen he's a 270 out of 365. so so
you're working 270 it's like having five
to eight car accidents a day
15 to 30 minutes you're running jumping
back dropping all this stuff that's
insane too to the
credit goes to the body by the way how
capable we are so many times are like
there's no way in the world i can do
this and i've had four kids you watch
the body have a baby you're like how did
how do you do that the body is so much
more capable than we think we we think
it is but going back to uh what you're
talking about here the greatest of all
time you said rick is at the top brick
flare hawk is in the conversation he
said all this stuff but let's go to peak
who peaked the most for one year two
year three years like
that's what i'm saying
yeah they'll say the greatest boxer of
all time is ali right but the greatest
peak of all time isn't it tyson like
yeah so who would be the greatest peak
would you put goldberg at the top i
would say him or austin because they
were so hot rock
rock kind of
crazy
you know uh but was really like if
austin and
mcmahon
don't have that feud
where basically like giving the finger
to you to your boss you know and people
love that like steve changed the game
the nwo took it like you never would
have thought wcw could have competed
with wwe but when
us you know when we did nwo
we kicked their ass for like bishop has
a show uh um a podcast called 83 weeks
in 83 weeks we kicked their ass
and then that whole austin and mcmahon
thing happened and it started to shift
to tide again you know and and that's
where how did that happen how did the
friction between the two happen what
caused it what was the tipping point
the vince was is probably the you know
maybe the greatest heal of all time
because he yes he he fully commits
and
he was not afraid to have you know have
austin in this scenario shine him and it
was really you know it was it's just
great television and uh you know
everybody wants to not everybody but
many people want to knock their boss out
not true over here over here
don't put that
when you say heel this is someone who
plays the villain yes right yes
walk us through that because i assume
most people want to be the hero no the
hogan the good guy no you're saying most
people want to play the heel every
pretty much every guy who starts yeah
wants to be the heel really fun to be j
are you in
it's fun it's easy to get people to hate
you
it's really hard
to get people to love you
you've gotta really be vulnerable
uh you've gotta you've gotta show
something that they can identify with
for me it was
the underdog you know
jim ross called me the greatest
overachiever of all time and in my hall
of fame speech i said to be an
overachiever you must first be an over
believer
and it's so true
when i was inducted to jake in the hall
of fame and you have to understand
before jake moved into my place and
anybody who's never seen the
resurrection of jake the snake it's on
amazon prime along with another
documentary we just put out called
relentless
um
but it's dark because it's addiction but
it will make you laugh
it will make you cry
most of all it'll inspire you because
jake just didn't burn bridges as we call
that you know
jake nuked them
like he was never gonna take he had said
so many bad things about wwe and vince
mcmahon
you know again
when you're addicted you do things that
you don't do when you're
beating the addiction what was he
addicted to
booze pills coke crack
you know i mean everything
and because jake helped me
to like i don't ever get
without dusty rose there's no diamond
dallas page without jake there's no
three-time world champion without the
both of those guys guiding me when i
needed them
i'm not a hall of famer but i was
because i
being 35 like i said earlier was the
hardest thing i ever did hitting that
mat in the beginning
but it was the best thing never happened
to me because i was smarter than i would
have been at 35
you know what i mean
so i should just say at 25 right you
know 25 i i would have done a lot of
stupid things
and
i don't think i ever would have had the
career i had
and it was pretty in everything that i
do it's like when jake comes into
the crib and i called it the
accountability [ __ ]
um
when he comes in there
the number one thing i want him to
understand
is
you are
the story you tell yourself that inner
voice
you know we all have it you know if it's
i this is funny because i'm preparing
for a speech that i'm going to do
for someone georgia's corporation
and um
about 10 years ago i heard that harvard
did
um
did a uh
uh
one of the things where they get a group
of people together focus group focus
group and
they
i heard that 72 percent
of the people
things that we worried about never
happened so i thought oh i'm preparing
for this i'm gonna actually i'm gonna
look it up i wanna see that study
harvard never did a study on the
worrying thing
uh
but
cornell did
but it wasn't 72
it was 85
following people over an extended period
of time
85 percent of things they worry about
never happen and it gets better than
that
of that 15
79 percent
handled the adversity
way better than they thought they would
and many of them said i'm glad it
happened because i learned something
from it
so really
97
according to this study by a kind of
decent school you know cornell
um
ninety percent of things we never would
never worry we worry about never happen
so again jake let's tell change the
story
like that you tell yourself like when he
came in
and it was more like he was waiting to
die and when someone died he was pissed
it wasn't him
he never had dreams anymore because you
were there's so much fog on your brain
from the coke and the crack and the
booze and the pills
you know so when he when he got there
the first thing i do and the same thing
and we talked about this earlier the
show we're filming right now called
change or die
and the first thing i do is change what
they eat
like
no gluten
no dairy
no gmos
organic
or
what god created
you know because
when
what i get people eating it affects
their mindset is they're so beat up and
hurt jake and scott were so beat up and
i couldn't believe how bad a shape they
were in physically
you change the food they eat
because our food sucks
in this country it's
it's criminal what the lobbyists and the
big corporations have done to our food
just watch food inc genetic neglect our
gmo omg
and then you'll have a little bit of an
insight these are all things i make
people watch and things they have to do
to be a part of what i'm doing
so jake and those guys so now they
change what they eat
they already start feeling better
now my workouts my ddp yoga or i called
ddpy why because i want people to stop
call it just [ __ ] yoga because it's
not
it's yoga rehab old school calisthenics
and something i call dynamic resistance
which is flexing and engaging
as you're moving
so
just like lifting weights
time under tension
so what happens
every time you flex or engage a muscle
your heart
has to beat faster get the blood
to the muscle
so what ends up happening is you're
getting the cardiovascular
workout
breaking up scar tissue and creating
mobility
strengthening your core a different
level all with minimal joint impact now
you guys i've been sitting here for the
last hour
oh he's getting up y'all watch out
back out can you get a camera so you can
get up get up get a mic closer to your
ddp okay so it's good you can lift it up
so
when i blew my back out this
was my flexibility
yeah you know i've been sitting here the
whole time right this is cold
damn he's all the way down insane
but
flexibility 65 years old 66. hey but
who's counting you looking great core
shape core balance core strength is a
whole different animal be able to stand
here and talk to you and grab either one
of my feet
and grab it and pull it over my head
[ __ ] and have a conversation with you at
six foot four
228 pounds of twisted steel and sex
appeal
that that's and 66. years young
your wife must love that move whatever
that was my wife makes me look like i'm
not pliable at all
she's amazing and she's broken her back
twice
so
my my point is with the program
what happened to me when i was wrestling
with kevin nash and it was a tag match
and kevin picked me up for the powerbomb
that he does
he's six foot ten legit
and he's throwing me trying to get me to
go flat
but when i hit it wasn't that bump
it was the proverbial straw that broke
the camel's back i ruptured my l4 and l5
so god gave us this incredible spine
right in between are these amazing
things called this but they're like
shock absorbers
well take a jelly donut
and do that
now she becomes bone on bone
and
i don't know how i did it all i know is
so much of this
reaching and stretching and
strengthening i'm constantly creating
traction
because
i'm trying to pull those bones off each
other
i was told by three different spine
specialists when this happened that i
was never wrestle again
i just did sign the multi-million dollar
big deal and i'd never gotten paid
before that
so the money was a factor
but it was more the dream
i just got there and now i mean i'm as
high as you can be i'm up there with
everybody according to pro wrestling
illustrated 97 and 98 i'm number four in
the world
austin's one i'm four
he's 35
he's 30 32
i'm 42.
crazy so
i'm i'm obviously i'm in the
conversation of the top 10 easily
and
for me i got to get back there i just
got to get back there because i got to
prove you can do this
in less than three months
i'm that guy in less than three months
in less than three months but i didn't
do it
no 20 minutes a day
i started with 20 minutes a day
twice a day and i was doing yoga in the
beginning in the first three weeks i
felt a significant difference i was like
wow this is really helping
i had to figure out modifications all my
workouts are surrounded around
modifications like i said bedflex starts
off in bed
chair force
sits in a chair
stand strong holds on to the chair
so you can create balance again and
strength and get up and get down and it
just helps you
make it easier so you can get to that
next spot of breaking up the scar tissue
and creating the mobility like i said
less than three months i'm back in the
ring at 42 they said my career is over
at 43 i'm the world champ now understand
whether and i put it like this like
world championship that's our oscar
okay u.s title intercontinental that's
our emmy you know and so forth like
there's dates like you're drawing you're
bringing people to the crowd like those
belts all these fans have them because
it's like it's
it's part of the nostalgia that goes
with it
and
it's you know as far as my program
it's just for me in the beginning for
years and i started sharing it with some
of my buddies and in 2004 i said
i'm gonna make i'm gonna turn this into
something so me and my business partner
dr craig herron we wrote a book on it we
called it yoga for regular guys
back then that's what i was calling it
and
for years you know i made a dvd series
up uh and it was just the workouts and
then
i put together a whole program with the
food and you know the um
the uh the inspirational part
it still didn't go anywhere it took
eight years
to become an overnight
success and doesn't it usually work that
way though by the way that's that's how
it does it's like oh it's like the ten
thousand hour thing yep you know and in
this scenario arthur borman's video went
viral and this was a disabled vet that
i'd helped it was um five foot six
297 pounds couldn't walk without the
knee braces back bracing to wrap around
keynes
he starts every single person who got my
program it was just dvds i would send
them an email there was no auto send
today i do have auto send but back then
there was no autos
i sent it i cut paste put their name on
it sent it to him and i said am i trying
to sell you anything i want to thank you
i call people all the time who get my
program and say hey hey is uh jenny
there
uh yeah i was speaking i go ah this is
ddp
who
i go
ddp diamond space uh ddp yoga
you're calling me i just does this
remind you of anything
does this remind you of that does the
same thing the value is out there it's
the most entertaining part of what we do
let me ask you something while we're on
this topic
you've always been a fit guy yeah i mean
this guy was in the army he was a
bodybuilder i don't know if you've got
these pictures but this guy's i mean
he's really great you guys are the same
size pretty much
but lately you've been working out more
than ever you're getting up at 6am and
you're doing hardcore workouts yeah
he's telling you all the benefits he's
66 he's all he's bending over like how
much better do you feel since you've
changed
your you know physical workout regimen
every morning your life night and day
night and day i mean it's not even a
question about what it does to your body
if i don't work out i just don't feel
better
it's very weird to display if you look
at that picture right there look at that
guy to the left look at that guy i'm 6 1
five to the left
and then to the right i'm in the army
that's my army barracks on the bottom
click on that one what about that
look at the pictures it's all flex
magazine it's all angel tavis go down a
little bit this one dude pat are you
kidding me dude no that's right valley
total fitness culver city in the
basement you were ready for the ring
hey brother you listen here right now
but but
do what he just did at 66 years old yeah
i'm 43 to be able to do that in 23 years
right that's like pinnacle i the only
thing i know what to do is to be 43
years old i only know 43 and less than
that i have no clue what it is at 66. so
that's just major problems and respect
brother for you to do what you're doing
uh the way you the way you just stood up
and did that so so you helped that man
out you helped a lot of different guys
out to change their lifestyle
uh with the drugs you were talking about
earlier when he said jake i would look
at him he just said he didn't have
another dream just there's no other
dream that he was looking forward to
every time somebody died he was hoping
it's him right so you helped shape that
mindset of somebody like him
to look forward to the dream is that
kind of what you did well
he had a really really really really
really dark childhood
and he carried that and it probably
helped them do some really great
interviews later
um
but we were doing when i proved jake
into my house and then later scott as
well
um
everybody thought i was crazy like i was
bringing addicts like everybody gave up
on both of them
kevin nash didn't give up on scott hall
but besides that everybody given up on
both of those guys
and when jake came in
i mean we got interviewed by deadline
and you know in yahoo sports and hbo
sports came like everyone's like they
were so blown away by the story
and
i didn't look at it as bringing an attic
into my house i look at it as bringing
it to my brother who literally and both
of those guys were very instrumental in
my career having the career i had
and jake would when he get on his thing
he'd start talking about this dark [ __ ]
again and i looked at the guy and i said
can you hold on a second i just want to
talk to him for a minute and i pulled
him in the next room
i said bro
i get you have this past
but if you keep holding on to this pass
we're never going to get by that i go
what about all the amazing things you
have eight kids
and right now
four of them are talking to you again
that's a big deal right he goes of
course it is i go yeah
nobody would book you for more than 500
bucks
at the time he was making like 2 500.
i go you're up five times in your
booking because people know they can
count on you
what about all the amazing things that
are happening in your life
and
he's just started changing it then he
would walk up the people because he's
doing my program right
and he's feeling so much better in the
beginning he's got to use the chair he's
got to use this he's got to use that
all of a sudden he doesn't use any of
that
and he's so much stronger has so much
more confidence that's the number one
thing that ddpy builds
confidence
because people can't do that in the
beginning bringing their foot over their
head
but then they can
you know it's crazy i'm watching and i'm
listening to the relationship the calls
the lifting up the motivation the
uh looking at uh scott and saying here's
what i want you to do shave the mustache
have a you know four o'clock shave more
form at two o'clock you know i've never
had this mustache it's 15 years old
don't worry about it that's the problem
we got to cut it off
it's it's the
you doing the management part at first
but they said you can't do it anymore
it's very obvious you would have made a
great manager if you would have
continued doing that you're great in
sales you're great on relationship you
could have made a hell of a sales leader
you could have made a hell of a
you you know because you're also looking
at people how you can improve them right
you're looking at everything on how you
can improve them you're watching tape
you're watching you could have gone in a
different field and done very very well
for yourself whether it was wrestling or
not just just from watching that career
earning for somebody like you
what is courier earnings for somebody
like you what kind of money did you make
in wrestling wrestling when it was all
said and done
probably made close to
six or seven million and what did you
make outside of it while you're
wrestling i'm talking like sponsorship
you know stuff like that did you get a
lot of that as well
there was some but nothing that was
significant but since
then
like i can say it took eight years for
it it took eight years in wrestling
before i made money before my you know
career blew up it was an overnight
success same thing
with ddp yoga and then eight years and
i've made
eight times that eight times that yeah
just from your program but maybe maybe
six six times 40 million bucks that's a
lot of money that's solid money to be
able to do that in wrestling who's the
highest paid of all time like who's made
the most money the goat is rick but i
don't think rick's the highest i mean i
gotta put the rock up there i would say
i would say hulk because remember hulk
rocks rock if you take overall wealth
the rock's the king the rock
the rocks the mack daddy because he's
making 30 million dollars a movie now
you know i'm talking strictly not
outside i'm talking strictly
right from the wrestling world i would
gotta say cena over here i would say
john cena would be up there sure
uh but um i would say hulk would have
been upstairs that's just for the year
yeah i'm curious to know what the all
time is i'm curious to know like if it's
you know uh all-time
highest paid
wrestler i'd be so curious to know what
it what the okay there you go mick foley
18 million chris
jericho 18 million keep going
kurt angle 25 million interesting you
got hulk 25 million yeah but i think
that's net worth now what they think
that's the net worth you know and i
don't really know how much of that is
because these these are numbers people
kind of pull together vince is an easy
one to figure out because triple h
wouldn't be up there triple h oh he
absolutely would be
absolutely like one yeah but again he
also is part of the uh
if you're talking just wrestling though
yeah like money you made off just
wrestling because because it says rock
is worth 400 but it's not from wrestling
right yeah
it's on everything yeah but without his
wrestling without his wrestling base
rock's not the right oh my god you know
i mean yeah when i saw him do saturday
night live the very first time i said i
said to myself gonna be the biggest star
in the world you knew that knew it
because
he can do anything like he taught
himself guitar like there's such things
that the rock did like he would
it's amazing some of the things that he
came up with like he wrote a song you
know and he'd figure six songs like
crazy
funny stuff that that and he just is
just an amazing performer like he has
changed and opened the door
for wrestlers as actors
like people can't because wrestling
people a lot of people look down their
nose well guess what hollywood the
biggest star in the world's
a wrestler and not a guy who walked away
from it still does so much stuff for us
he's got a show on tv called young rock
you know that he produces as a kid him
as a kid with all the wrestlers he never
turns his nose away
from
his
fan base where it all started and but
the rock's the most loved guy on the
planet i honestly god believe and i know
it's i said this way a long time ago but
he could be the president united states
we talk about it all the time yeah and
the i mean but i'm serious discussion by
the way but do you really want that and
you know what he might i don't know
but i think he would be amazing i
remember one point they were kidding
around about it and saying tom hanks is
vice president i think that we they
totally kill everybody there what do you
think about that video rock dude calling
out trump where are you where is he yeah
he kind of almost sounded like batman
you know he went straight to trump bro
yeah and you know i i that
it took balls because all those freaking
red guys they love him well that kind of
pissed a bunch of them off yeah but yeah
when people say to me like you're a
republican or a democrat i say i think
you both suck
you know i don't think either one's
trying to help the other which is us
the other not trying to help us they
don't give a [ __ ] about themselves and
their own agendas and they all lie
about everything and never get busted
you know it's mind-boggling trump would
make appearances at wwe would he not he
i think didn't he fight vince mcmahon
he's a he is a in the celebrity wing
hall of famer yeah
have you ever had have you ever had to
have you ever interacted with trump has
you ever been there when the whole
wrestling thing i never was there when
he was doing that i met him once when he
literally first got with his wife and it
was at a elizabeth glacier eight
foundation thing and he was super nice
he was super nice you know the guy
you know i i hated the stuff he did on
twitter and now the big whole thing with
elon
and twitter and everything but
you know i hated
because he really could have just turned
the curb
he could have turned the curve once he
got in there because he's a very
charismatic cat you know and
you know he could have been i to me
could have been much better
at doing the president thing
you know and trying to pull us together
you know but it is what it is again i
think all politicians are [ __ ]
you brought up he brought up the elon
musk twitter thing i mean this is
something you've we've been talking
about for weeks now
i'm sure you've now that it's been 24
hours since it's happened how are you
processing this since yesterday they
realized the poison pill was gonna
backfire and they were gonna be in court
for the rest of their lives and finally
they caved and they said ilan
you know [ __ ] we can't do nothing about
it i guarantee you this took place i'm
telling you right now i may be wrong
lawyers they had a meeting with the
legal team but they said okay
what do what can we do at this point if
we pull the poison pill
you can pull the poison pill just make
sure
when the market finds that you didn't
let elon musk buy twitter
and he sells off his 9.2 the same amount
of shares he owns as morgan stanley
just make sure you can make the stock go
up the next three quarters because if it
goes
below 30 after you push elon away
and he sells off the other 9.2 if it
goes below 30 we're gonna be in court
for five ten years if you guys are okay
with that then use the poison pill if
not let the man buy the company and then
finally everybody looked around and
there were certain people that probably
still didn't want to do it and they
wanted to still use the poison pill but
some of the guys that are just on the
board to help the company make more
money said sell the company i'm telling
you i think the decision was made that
logically and then they sold off to ilan
they couldn't do anything elon
one thing you got to say about this guy
man listen you know
name the greatest trolls of all time
trump's on that list
if you say trolls right name the
greatest trolls of all time
they call jake paul's coming up but he's
a young troll i'm talking like legendary
trolls of all time you got to put him up
there
you got to put uh uh
you know oh
who else would you put in the wrestling
world and ufc you got to put conor in
that world as a
great troll oh [ __ ] talking i'm talking
about
i'm talking getting under the skin type
of a yeah so text exchange came up right
you want to show the text exchange
between muslim
gates i don't know if you saw this or
not uh so here's a text exchange that
came out make it a little smaller so we
can see it
uh so the first text goes out can you do
it or no exactly the top part of it
apparently apparently bill gates hits up
elam was to discuss philanthropy on
climate change but elon asked if he
still had a half a billion auto short on
tesla bill said yes he hasn't closed it
out so elon told him to get lost no idea
if this is true lol
well elon responds here's what he said
on the bottom right there he says do you
still have a half a million dollars a
hundred percent he says sorry but i
cannot take your philanthropy on climate
change seriously when you have a massive
short position against tesla the company
doing
the most to solve climate change and so
people ask elon musk and look what he
said go out there and click on his
twitter account to see if this is
[ __ ] and if this is real right no
you should first go to his account and
then you can go to that trolling he
responds go a little lower you'll see
one of the ones when he responds and he
says that is the text exchange i don't
know who got it go a little lower go a
little lower ah you respond somewhere
there that he did respond okay anyways
go back to the uh
post that he put up there bill gates and
then he post this in case you need to
lose a boner fast that's bill gates and
that image of apple so you're basically
saying that elon musk is one of the
greatest trolls of all time
what i'm saying to you is what i'm
saying to you is
this guy
cornered twitter's
board to say i dare you to not let me
buy the company i dare you i think
that's how it happened what was the poll
you did yesterday about elon musk i
asked the question i said what
percentage of you uh uh how will you
react with elon musk uh uh what do you
call it uh buying twitter number one are
you leaving and i said number two uh
will you be more active number three you
know you know david [ __ ] you know
something like that and i'll be more
active nothing will change and then who
cares you know how many people said
leaving two percent everybody was like
yeah i'm going to be more active the one
that won the most was i'll be more
active don't forget what elon did along
came out and he said do you guys know
the top 10 most followed people on
twitter
they rarely ever tweet he says do you
know that justin bieber hasn't tweeted
but so many times do you know that such
and such person do you know that barack
obama only tweets this many times why do
we have the top biggest accounts that
are not active on twitter he's asking
the right question the whole blue you
know that everybody wants that blue
check mark of course he says why don't
we just give the blue check mark to
everybody that pays 299 a month why
don't we do that
if you pay 2.99 a month let's get rid of
all the bots if you pay 299 a month
you're not fake because all these people
are creating these fake accounts right
let's eliminate all these fake accounts
that are out there because they're not
paying 299 a month i mean i love what
this guy is doing so anybody and
everybody can get the blue chip if you
pay 299 a month whatever the fee is
going to be now he's allowing you know
the new ceo made a few changes that they
allow you to put 10 minute videos we
couldn't do that before was 2 20. now
you can't put a 10 minute video anyways
the market's very very happy however
yesterday the legendary brian stelter
which i don't know if you follow him is
a famous wrestler from cnn
[Laughter]
he goes by the thumb
[Music]
he's a famous i can't we can't play that
but he said something he says well i
just want you to think about this
imagine you have two parties to go to
one party you can say whatever you want
to say and you're free and another party
you go to people have to be a little bit
more responsible with what they say
which party would you want to go to and
then somebody comments on my tweet and
he says i can't imagine him having ever
been to a single party in his life
before because the biggest thing is
people don't believe the guy's 34 years
old that guy to the left is 34 years old
that's about he's 34 years old brian do
yourself a favor contact diamond dallas
page on how to look
did you see the latest with jack dorsey
now
you see what jack dorsey had to say
about elon i sent that to you on slack
what do you think jack dorsey's response
about elon buying twitter is first of
all what do you think let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question how
many conversations do you think ilan and
jack have had in the process him buying
twitter what do you use non-stop are you
kidding me like you know how he said he
said it's a it's a fantastic brotherhood
brotherhood right dude these guys are
paypal mafia brotherhood
they're texting calling they've lived by
a certain code that nobody else knows
about jack's known it for a longest time
elon's already told jack i want you to
be on the board you know all this
conference
they've already had the conversations
and on top of that what did come out
yesterday which was interesting because
i said the five things that was going to
happen once elam bought it i said number
one he's gonna buy twitter take it
private number three he's gonna do
whatever he's doing with uh brady's
picture to be eliminated then it's gonna
be trump's gonna be back and then
mainstream's gonna lose their mind on
all this stuff but the one thing that
the story is not coming out is even if
twitter lets trump back on he may not
want to come back on because he's still
pushing truth so oh get out of here with
this true social was yesterday socially
has officially
put the nail in the coffin you don't
think he's just gonna come back to
twitter now
that's not true let's read that right
there trump will not return to twitter
even as ilan must purchase his platform
will begin his own truth so yeah well by
the way i don't think that's a smart
move i don't think that's a smart move
no i don't think
go back to jack dorsey's quote uh about
elon as i say even melania doesn't use
truth like the only person that uses
truth is trump and nobody can get on it
right
elon is the singular solution i trust
that's some pretty high praise but it's
not it's not this is he he said this to
elon before he said it to public
he said this to ilan before he said it
it's all a work yeah that's what we call
our business it's all set up
you know and for this cat with all the
bazillions of dollars he has
he's kind of known you know he has a
plan
and the plan is like you said was
already discussed before it ever went
out there and he already knew who the
votes were coming in that he needs and
who else need who's going to partner
with them you know to me i don't i don't
believe anything anymore you know it's
like just do your thing elon go for it
you know well you know they say
everyone's got a plan until they get
punched in the face yeah and that's what
happened
by mike tyson the guy in the flight did
you see that that was that pissed me off
so bad like that i watched that kid he
was really aggravating i don't know why
the stewardess didn't come over and go
you
sit down shut up yeah i mean something i
mean he would really had a record
apparently he had a record and he's been
i don't know there were some stories
about the guy that came up about him
having a record did you see that tyler
or no
yeah he has several different charges
he's been arrested for look yeah clearly
the guy's got a screw loose if you're
talking [ __ ] to mike tyson
clearly you've got a uh you know a loud
mouth that you're drinking
or an agenda an agenda you know 50
minutes so here's my question ddp you're
a massive dude i mean
how often does somebody say what's up
you got to go nobody taught something to
you never everybody they know who i am
yeah and the people who don't you know
you can see by the way i carry myself
i'm not the guy i know you just say do
something with my wife
that's a different story but with me you
can't piss me off i just you know i i
eliminate yeah your voice what do you
think i want to get i really don't get
that ever because like i mean i help a
lot of people but what do you think was
going through tyson's mind i mean i'm
talking oh my god putting yourself in a
position of a high profile major athlete
tough guy which you are
and tyson is sitting on the plane you
know doing his things probably on a
mushroom or two it's certainly high
and this jackass is just going off on
him i'm getting put yourself for tyson
he's getting the stewardess and go can
you move that [ __ ] yeah or can you
shut him up you know he's bothering my
wife because i'm not going to let him
step into my space
you know and you know when you're in
this scenario there there's there's an
ulterior motive it's not just maybe in
the beginning he was a little excited
about it but after a while he's just
being an [ __ ] you know he has no
respect for anyone's space and he's got
some kind of issue you know but the
stewardesses
you know they're pretty strict these
days you know since 9 11 you know it's a
different answer how did the student was
he in the first place the internet never
loses it's undefeated look at this right
here
marshall and then mike tyson beating the
[ __ ] out of some guy
right
how did the stewardess not show up how
did other people not see what was about
to go on again i thought i'm looking at
that i'm going is this a work i mean
where is this thing
right being like hitting the button now
what kind of um and mike doesn't deserve
to be treated like that in any way shape
or form you talk about a guy who's
turned his life around
interviewed him for an hour yeah and it
was one of the coolest things talking to
that guy but question for you how many
guys who were in wrestling
let's just say he lost to another guy
that was the one that you know let's
just say vince or eric is building a guy
up to be like a face
and you're lost but how many guys were
like well
listen if this was a real fight i'd beat
the hell out of it was there any guys
like that that were like of course there
were street fighters that were like i
would crush you if we got into a street
fight yeah but it's not why you get into
the business it's a show yeah it's a
show early earlier years like yeah they
call them shooters you know like if he
didn't want to lose you weren't losing
like nobody was going to move andre to
giant around
if he didn't want to be let moves around
you know because andre was like
and big show was the same way i remember
a big show i was wrestling with them and
i did this one spot and big show was you
know seven foot one five hundred pounds
yeah shack size yeah shack size bigger
bigger and they sit against each other
look at that yeah
there they are right there and i go to i
go to uh shoot him off he reverses me
and he goes to clothesline me and i
hooked him and i'm
his arm's like this and my legs over
here my arms are here and then i slide
down and now i'm laying on my back and
i'm trying it's called a sunset flip i'm
trying to pull him over and this is a
giant's body
and then he reaches down and he grabs me
by the throat right and he's going to
pick me up now i'm on my back i'm going
to give him a boost i'm going to
and
slide so it makes it easier
my foot slipped
and now i'm dead weighting him
and he picks me up like i'm five
i'm 250
pounds the big show you're talking about
yes
picks me up like i'm out of the way
right so type in big show ddp holy crap
he picks you up like you're five like i
was five years old and i was looking
down everybody went whoa
because you could really see like it was
a shoot and he's got me by the throat
here i'm looking down on him i go okay
now don't kill me
and drop me on my back but uh you know
it was uh just like moments like that
really stick out my in touch like oh
okay let me let me ask you it's a past
question this is a real question
he asked like you know
competitive nature who doesn't want to
lose
if you actually had to pick a tag team
partner in a real life fight like oh
[ __ ] is going down you know and i want
this guy
i got one guy that's on my side and a
real fight is happening who's your first
pick his name would be
ming
also went by to
which is his real name samoan dude
friggin
sweetest guy on the planet
but
you would not want to be on a bad side
really pull him up
this guy was a certified badass
[ __ ] yeah put up uh put up
m-i-n-g there's right there it looks
like he looks who's got the hawaiian
shirts all up yeah everybody
the king thing though why is he your
first pick because he was just notorious
for
you know bringing
everyone you know like
ben skye alive really yes it was known
yes everyone like throughout wwe wcw
everyone knew everyone what was it about
him that just can kick anyone down
i think there was i don't know i don't
remember the exact thing i wasn't there
but it was like he beat up five guys
yeah like in a bar fight because they
would like some why would you pick on
that guy
or challenge that guy like uh and
they're looking for trouble yeah and i
don't i don't know the exact story but i
mean one of the greatest sweetest guys
you've ever met though how do you
balance
being like you're saying
the greatest sweetest guy ever with also
being able to beat the [ __ ] out of five
guys at once how does that yin yang
balance work because he was a great
human being and you know he was also a
badass
you can be both yeah you guys like you
could be a manly man and also do ddpy
yoga absolutely and friggin chuck zedo
you know chuck zeal's one of the best
some [ __ ] on the planet but he is a
freaking sweetheart man
you know guy who was president of the
hell's angels new york chapter for 25
years
sweetheart guy man
that's great
i asked this question because you know
in the nfl
you had a marvin harrison that who you
know legendary player wide receiver yeah
yeah of course but do you know like the
reputation marvin he was feared by
everybody
marvin had
you know links to gangs and you know
murder you know some some real stories
ray karuth everybody sees and knows like
oh he went to jail
jones you know some of those stories but
marvin was like you just don't cross the
line with marvin harrison he had that
about you didn't know that no you should
look it up marvin harrison is known as a
guy that was
feared respected you didn't cross that
guy that's why sometimes you wonder the
background of these guys by the way
different style
eric bishop you talk about eric who you
know he's doing what he's doing and you
said if he would have continued you know
at one point you guys are competing
those guys are about to lose bankruptcy
all this stuff what is the biggest
difference between eric and the way
vince led
and marketed and told story what was the
difference well i think more than
anything and this was great when bishop
was running wcw even we were doing great
it was constant conflict with the office
meaning like
to turner people who were owned by ted
turner not ted but their people looked
down at wrestling
and when vince was fighting for his life
his whole companies are wrestling
superstars you know he took away lord
wrestling whatever you know sports
entertainers
it's his company it's his lifeline it's
his legacy it's everything and eric
didn't have that
if he could have been doing it on his
own who knows what would have happened
but you know you know when you work in
the corporate world you know you know
you've been all through that and it's so
hard then there's the jealousy thing and
you know all of that when it's your
company
and it's your brand
yes like and vince is the really the one
with hulk that
changed the whole format by the way you
know who gets a lot of credit for that
story you just told dana white because
dana she's only a 10 owner of the
company
and dana was able to work you know
politics wme two owners came they bought
it for two million he got 10 percent and
he was still able to move it up even
though it's not his company he's only a
10 guy at the company it's not like he's
51 there's a difference between sure
dana and vince but dana still was able
to pull off the product which product to
to the audience that doesn't i'm going
to show something here on the internet i
want these guys to see on youtube but
which one do you do you think ufc
today's
surpassed
the audience and the eyeballs that
wrestling gets or do you think wrestling
is still ahead of ufc i think that ufc
would be bigger at this point because i
think it's very cyclical wrestling is
it's up and it's down and it's really
like it's harder now to really
understand how many people are watching
and give you an example um and this was
genius so everybody thought it was like
oh god what a waste of time wwe network
you know oh they're out they're losing
money they're this they're that and
everything
well i guess it was two years ago vince
leased
not sold
but leased
the network
to peacock
for one billion dollars
for five years lease leased
they don't own [ __ ]
they are using because they what is the
most important thing on any whether it's
paramount peacock content a thousand
percent well now we've got a ton of
different shows it looked like when
vince was gonna you know wwf
was gonna trade to wwe oh my god they're
they've ruined his brand and they spent
all these years you know and vince
fought for it didn't get it
best thing ever happened to him this
time i'll use an example of this a
second but
so many times
what looks like the worst thing to ever
happen to you
can be the best
and what
when i blew
when i wrote when i tore my rotator cuff
and they let me go when i was 36
jake came and lived with me for three
months and then got me booked wherever
we went to
he became my mentor on the how i told
stories and it took years to really
become a really good storyteller but if
i don't tear my rotator cup and get
fired
that never happens
when i blow my back out
and they tell me my wrestling career is
over
and i've just signed this multi-million
dollar contract it's gonna go bye-bye
and i come back
great that i get back and live the dream
but what looks like the worst thing ever
happened to me
is not only the best thing ever happened
to me
it's the best thing to happen to jake
to scott
to people who are going to change or die
i've got
hundreds of thousands of transformations
when i tell people
don't listen to a word i say about ddp
yoga don't listen to a word
community
one of my buddies chris gabriano started
this just page on facebook just a
regular page ddp yoga
one word
and it was a thousand people
and then there was five
and now there's over 70 000 people
you have to read
that page
you will never believe what people put
up there you see remember when and we
both do this we call people
we show people we really actually give a
[ __ ] about what we're doing that's very
very very rare
so
in this scenario anyone who came to this
one site i had originally called team
ddp yoga
i would welcome them
every single person me
and then it built into this thing on
facebook
which they saw the way i would come
through
and talk to people and i do the likes
and i put comments it's me stop for
somebody imitating me
and i'll get on there for like two hours
and just do that
so much so my app my ddp yoga now app
which i always tell people don't go to
itunes or google play they charge too
much
i don't charge anywhere near as much if
you go to ddpyoga.com and i give you
seven days free to try it
the bottom line is every monday's
motivational monday
every tuesday there's a new workout by
the way there's over 300 of both of
those
uh every wednesday's a new cooking show
gluten-free dairy-free healthy great
tasting food because i don't care how
you know healthy something is if it
don't taste great i'm not eating it
not eating it yeah and
how i feel is what when i'm feeding my
body is how my body is healing itself
your food will heal you and food will
[ __ ] you fake food
like you'd never get me to eat fast fake
food
ever now i know what's in it i'm not
eating that [ __ ]
but again healing your body so back to
the fabulous
the fabulous fridays
i just go on that facebook page
70 000 people
you know stuff just keeps rolling
through
so i go on there and i just start
picking stories
because i want to read someone's story
and what they wrote
and the pictures they put up of
themselves because i've got those six
pictures front side full forward and
one's putting the foot up in the air you
can't fake that [ __ ]
so when you see a person who can't pick
their foot off the ground a foot
and then six months later he's holding
over his head that's core strength a
different level but the stuff that they
write can you pull up on facebook pull
it up there and let's let's see if what
people
ddp yoga one word on facebook
yeah one word facebook and let's just
see just some of the
okay just just zoom down
is that it uh
i think that's a ddp yoga one i'm
talking about the members one
just go up there and just put in the
search ddp yoga one word
and you're saying one word because they
get the opportunity to describe
dedication no no just one word i wrote i
wrote it i originally would write it
you know um just pull up can you pull up
facebook
tyler you're about to get you're about
to get a diamond card right now buddy by
the way we do have a few callers that
people want to talk to you so here you
want to take some callers sure but
what's my point is you wouldn't believe
that [ __ ] the pictures
what what link would you want guys to go
if they want to find out more about it
do you want to go to the website or not
yeah go to the website
that's what i'm talking about this guy
do you believe that but look at him
right next to him wearing his thousand
uh uh hours on the app shirt look at
that look how much better he looks when
he's wearing the shirt over the home
believe it but women put up those
pictures
look at this drew was determined to
change his life in 16 months he went
from 390 to 210. insane now he's owning
his life by sharing a story and singing
with others and then talk about a
motivational monday brother
and that's and that's that's all my
company one you gotta the one i'm
talking about is the one members go
awesome and they help
each other there's never been a
community like it and that's the biggest
thing i'm the proudest of by the way did
you know viktor rivera
victor rivera yeah i know the name
victor rivera okay somebody asked in a
question do you know victor rivera i
don't know what that question means is
he a wrestler is he no i i know i know a
guy okay not he's not wrestling okay
let's bring victor rivera right now luis
muscle just asked the question dallas
they say competition breeds uh
innovation do you think vince will ever
have competition like the monday night
wars again
i can't imagine it you know just because
the oh the aew which is the new
wrestling program out there is really
good and the product's really good um
but it's like
the wwe is
oh i was down there at wrestlemania they
did two nights in a row of wrestlemania
with over 78 000 people one night and 84
000
the other night
two nights of that's crazy i have a
quick question about these people right
because i it's been forever since i've
been to a wrestling match
but you talked about being in la and
then going to kansas city and then
coming down to fort i mean just like
what's the crowd like at these wrestling
events what type of people
what type of energy what like maybe
i'm not saying politically but like
philosophically what do they stand for
tell us about the crowd at these events
the people who love wrestling
love wrestling you know and
they appreciate it they know it's a show
and they care about the characters
and they're ravenous man like
i've you can't imagine
like unless you're really at a live
event you've never seen wrestling you
know because when you see
how
they're part of the show
you know it's like
people like oh god they're booing him or
they're cheering him
it's really you want them to do either
you don't want them to do nothing
that's right powerful you don't want
them to do nothing by the way so uh
do we have callers yes
we have julian on the phone julian how
are you
good how you doing fantastic so what
question do you have for ddp
my question is did you get paid off of
your likeness being used in the nintendo
games
that you're a part of and
uh were you involved in any of the
um
any of the production in the games
um yeah i always got paid you know we
got some kind of vague the company gets
the major part of the vig and we you
know we get a little piece but it's
still late you know it's i call it
mailbox money you know um
uh
i've always had
anything to do with my character
i want to be there and go through the
moves and they like today they can put
these things all over you i mean i just
did one the other day um where you're
wearing this suit
and the way you walk and i've got a
pretty distinct swag walk that friggin
uh
you can tell like that characters that
person or you know how they do their
gestures and stuff so that's pretty
interesting the way they do it today
it's like these these video games look
like the real piece [ __ ] it looks it
doesn't matter like a video game it
feels like you're watching a show right
it's like you stepped into it
so uh nelson here says
uh love you ddp you're my childhood hero
can you talk about your experience
filming the guardians of justice love
your batman-esque character
that that's a new show that just came
out uh it's an adi shankar experience uh
a buddy of mine who uh is a very
talented cat and he's always way far
ahead of the cutting edge
he
put together
uh we were shooting this originally for
youtube it was just gonna be a bunch of
shorts and then
we had some pretty good stuff there so
we thought well let's turn it into a
movie because he's been a part of doing
walk among the tombstones and the gray
and judge dread so he's a real producer
and it was too long by the time we got
there in the meantime he was doing
something different with a show called
castlevania on netflix and they were
like what else do you have and he
brought up guardians of justice
and then
they started editing all the cgi and
there's eight different types of 2d
animation 3d animation and claymation
worked into
this story that's a series you know
seven episodes
dark satire and i you know batman never
gets older than 40 right
batman never gets older than 40. uh but
nighthawk he's in his 60s and he drinks
and he smokes and he takes painkillers
because he needs them and he kills for
the greater good you know and he and he
knows how to save the world uh and uh
it's it was a lot of fun to do and
now i'm a legitimate superhero
that's pretty sick okay john uh let's
take one more caller we have sammy on
the line sammy how you doing
hello sammy can you hear me
yes i can fantastic so what's your
question for ddp
yes uh my question is um i'm not
receiving the value that i'm paying for
at university uh i'm going to drop out
i'm worried that i'm making a terrible
mistake um what are you guys thoughts on
that what do you think about that this
kid's going to college he's thinking
he's wasting his time should he drop out
or continue going to school you know i
don't you know to me
i think every person who gets out of
high school first of all i love what
israel does where they make them go
right into the army for a year um you
know it's a great way to learn and grow
and a lot of people
like my daughter took off three years
before she started college she didn't
like it she quit and then she came back
and then she knew what she really wanted
to do i don't think so it depends how
old you are sammy you know
it depends on what you really believe in
what your passion is one thing i can
tell you and all three of us get this
whatever it is you're going to try to do
it should be something you love to do
because the key is to find something
that you love to do and figure out a way
to get someone to pay you to do it
you know because that's really
what it's not the american dream it's
the dream
world dream
and a lot of people are just going to
school just you know and getting
compiling all that debt
you know like i made my daughter when it
came down to it like fill out all your
loan papers no because i'm not going to
do that for you
i want you to do it i'm not going to
saddle you with debt you're going to
you know and then and she dropped out
and then she came back and now she's an
editor you know and she's doing
what she loves to do
so then you never feel like you're
working right
good for but but by the way the story
with you and jay-z what happened there
with the diamond stuff with you and i've
read about him like that this can't be
real but apparently it's a real story it
was real all i'm allowed to say you'll
appreciate this is the um
how am i saying now it's been so long
since i've said anything about it the
matter has been resolved
and i'll tell you what i got a lot of
respect for jay-z
uh just what he's done you know to help
a lot of people too you know so uh a lot
of respect is there a difference between
what it does and what you do look at
this tyler put this up there remember
when jay-z paid royalties to diamonds
people hand just now i can read this
but diamond dollar space it's pretty
epic because but it's not the same thing
yeah well my hands were open it was
close but it was it was all the same
thing and you know you own the diamond
baby yeah you know it's like he can do
whatever he wants with it
he was the guy that won
who was the guy that bought the
trademark to three-peat was it pat riley
yes because he won it and then somebody
used it and he sued them he says no
that's mine do you know this i think you
have riley owns he owns three pete he
then he owns three
are you guys are you guys watching
winning winning time on hbo max
oh you give the magic johnson patriots
i'm not watching that we watch man in
the arena and last time what happened
is it good this is this is so good to me
uh that guy john c reilly he's playing
jerry buss the kid who's playing magic
you're gonna think it's magic
like it's he's so good and he and he's
gotta watch it i haven't seen there's a
part where kareem abdul-jabbar is
talking to magic stad and you know magic
sail happy with everybody and he's and
you know kareem you know they stole it
yeah pretty stoic he goes
so has he always been this happy
and he goes yeah he goes so where are
you from and he his dad says like i'm
from mississippi
so i've seen it all you know from the
hanging corpses the whole deal yeah and
again
goes he goes yeah you have and and then
the you know the magic guy
is just he's just and the guys can ball
i mean these guys can go it's a really
fun
uh how many episodes is it how many i
would say there's probably six in right
now oh it's six in and it's all about
magic so it's about
magic coming jerry buss you know buying
the company and how we did it we want to
know that about jerry buss i'm
interested oh dude you're gonna you're
gonna love it because it's it's a lot
like what vince mcmahon did vince
mcmahon leveraged everything
to get the company was making all
these promises because that's what he
saw
and then it hap yo visions everything
like from when when steve the movie uh
the documentary we have also up right
now it's called relentless and it goes
for me blowing my back out to where we
are today and stone cold steve austin
like he lived with me
in l.a when i was
putting this whole thing together
and
he's like kid
what are you thinking you're never going
to get people to do yoga who wouldn't be
caught dead doing yoga it's not that i
don't believe in you kid cause you know
you're a miracle worker you know but you
know he's calling you kid yeah we call
each other
but he uh you know he didn't get it
and
the bottom line is i saw it
and i tell people all the time when i
when i inducted jake and hall of fame i
should never underestimate the power
you give someone by believing in them
more importantly
never underestimate the power you give
yourself
by believing in you
and that's what it takes and the guy kid
who called earlier you need to believe
in what you're doing sammy and what
you're and what your focus is sami
listen up man what what an advice so
daughter goes to college i want you to
sign the paperwork
that me
and then she drops out and then she goes
and becomes an editor well yeah she does
she got it for free got a degree and she
got a job and she's on her own she chose
to do she did all her fantastic well ddp
first of all this has been a blast
having you on man really enjoyed it
i'm so glad we did this the stories the
motivation it's like combination of a
bunch of different things again i'm
looking at you as a personality you
could have made one hell of a
sales leader manager
uh agent for many stars the the way you
motivate your speakers sure i mean he is
a motivational speaker but the point is
this could have gone many different
angles this was a blast happening by the
way gang in an hour we're gonna flip the
set around ddp and his new wife paige is
gonna come on my show the sauce cast and
it's gonna be like the late night show
yeah
and adam's very very prepared for this
interview so don't miss that one
we'll see you guys there take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you